let's a little concept work um there's a
term diegesis diegesis in the context of
film studies looking at tv shows and
movies is a
narrative plot it's the stuff that the
characters know is happening the things
that happen to them
non-diegetic events non-diegetic stuff
are things that we the viewers would see
but that they would not so like a
soundtrack and presumably a character
talking directly to camera like i'm
talking to you is uh in that sort of
breaking the fourth wall mode is some
kind of paradigisus right one of the
characters is aware of it nominally but
it's not really part of the story unless
sometimes it is you can tell i watched a
lot of moonlighting when i was a kid
i'm getting interested in levels of
digestives because i think a lot about
stories that are like making of stories
i've written some of them here at wired
we run them all the time other places do
too you know behind the scenes of your
favorite tv show or movie
that's another kind of paradigisus right
it's another narrative uh it's a story
of people trying to do things and the
characters are aware of what they're
doing but what they're trying to do is
make this other narrative so i guess if
you're doing levels you could have kind
of hyperdiagesis which would be stories
that other people tell about the
narratives and
hypodigesis or
maybe that's metadiogenesis narratives
that explain the structure of the
narrative
you know what's really good at this
stuff is
reality tv shows unscripted because
they'll combine all different kinds of
narratives all in one they've got the
things that actually happen the diagesis
but then also people commenting on them
from outside and those sort of i'm not
here to make friends confessionals
and then they'll have
shows that are on after the show that
talk about the show and then the press
of course covers things
that happen on the show as well it's a
it's a diegetic knot
i'm interested in this because um i'm
interested in doing magazines better uh
so what i've gotten interested in
in the past few years
is
the the
meta diagesis of making television shows
and movies i've been reading a lot of
scripts and i've been reading about how
scripts are made
you know who was cool about this was ron
moore the guy who ran the reboot of
battlestar galactica he uh used to
podcast uh and blog and at one point he
actually just recorded one of their
writers room sessions and i learned i
hadn't known this until that point that
they were creating their shows in much
the same way that we create our big
magazine packages there was a lot of
brainstorming there were people trading
ideas i didn't know there was a room
like that well now you can listen to
something like the nerdist writers panel
which is run by a tv writer a guy named
ben blacker who with his writing partner
ben acker does a another podcast a live
show called the thrilling adventure hour
that i also listen to sometimes and on
nerdist writer's panel he has tv writers
come on and just talk about how they
work on their various shows and often
there's a show that i know backward and
forward because it's you know three four
writers so then i get that narrative
level as well
and i've also had ben and ben on the
other podcast that i do here the audio
one the storyboard so now we are just in
a diegetic minefield of narrative layer
upon narrative layer
i'm doing this because i like learning
how to read scripts and because i like
tv shows but also because i'm trying to
learn how to do magazines better i'm not
very good at reading scripts yet but i
am learning some structural tricks and a
lot of what we do here is establish
structures try to figure out structures
not so that you would be able to tell
what we were doing because that would be
amateurish but so that the stories are a
cooler read
i'm trying to figure out what lessons
that drama writers
have and here's a meta-diegetic level
from their narrative what lessons they
can teach my metadiegetic level here at
the magazine will it work
i don't know it's a cliffhanger check it
out diagesis